diamondbacks turning the page on this
wednesday evening from the desert the
astros in town to take on the arizona
diamondbacks who at three and eight
looking to put a halt to a three-game
losing skid diamondbacks in the astros
the second of a three-game series and
your d-back starting pitcher is the
lefty robbie ray new mechanics to try
and get more efficient but in two starts
so far robbie has been over 90 pitches
and not gotten through the fifth inning
george springer will lead it off part of
the arsenal part of the mechanics right
there
that little glove tap and it worked
beautifully there 97 and he strikes out
springer matt says that is to help with
the timing and get him uh his arm
unstuck is the way matt just put it
now facing alex bregman with tonight
he's been throwing strikes so far for
the most part as bregman lines one into
left field that'll be down and towards
the corner alex bregman will take the
turn at first and he'll get into second
base with a two out double
bregman has reached base now 43
consecutive road games going back to
last year
[Applause]
out to center starling martay on the run
he's got it
and robbie ray puts up a goose egg in
the first lanes of colors on the mound
for your houston astros
on the ground pass lance diving stop
correa carlos correa
the defensive gem up the middle what a
great play by carlos correa we saw the
range vertically last night here we get
to see the range to the right
that ball was hit well off the bat of
cole calhoun
carlos in the right spot also worked a
lot on that first step last season it
shows right there so correa in scoring
position nobody out for the designated
hitter abraham toro
hey there's a ball in the center field
for a base hit correa is going to be
waved around he's going to score abraham
toro gives the ass shows a one-nothing
lead
toro at first base
still nobody out the batter is kyle
tucker
tucker drives one deep to right field
near baxter in the pool this ball's gone
kyle tucker
a tremendous shot to right center field
it's three nothing
tucker's first home run of the year
here's nick ahmed nick got on base a
couple of times last night
and a foul tip caught by maldonado
there's the first strikeout for lance
another one two three inning through
three after the three numbers
abraham torros the hitter had an rbi
single back in the second inning came
around to score
that ball sent into left field well hit
this ball carrying and this ball is gone
abraham toro his first home run of the
year his third major league home run and
he's giving the astros a four-nothing
lead
well that'll bring up cole calhoun
little left side of the infield wide
open for cole
gets into this one and shoots it toward
the right field corner that ball is
rolling rolling
here comes kettel marte he's rolling
along they're going to wave cole calhoun
all the way in here
it's a stand-up inside the park home run
for cole calhoun
well maybe not exactly the way they drew
it up but you'll take it it's 4-2 the
first five in the inning have reached
two runs in there loaded still nobody
out as peralta will be the hitter
peralta down the line here we go again
that's a fair ball that's in the corner
marte is home walker's the tying run
here comes escobar the freight trains
got a three-run triple
a five run fourth and vote sends one out
to deep right center field and that's
gonna get off the wall here comes
peralta and votes got an rbi double make
it six to four
and here is cattell marte who started
this fourth inning with a single to
right field
marte sends one to center mile straw
giving chase he's at the track and it's
off the wall
vote will score katel marte his second
hit in this fourth inning
and the diamondbacks with seven runs in
the fourth have a 7-4 lead the batter is
cole calhoun
who better be rested by now
there's one more out to springer in
right
here comes cattell
cole calhoun an inside the park home run
and an rbi single all in the same inning
and it's an eight run d backs fourth
still one and two on christian walker
walker lines it by bregman
here comes cole calhoun starling will
get third another rbi for christian
walker make it nine to four
that the d-back's hit for the cycle in
this inning
why ball for kyle tucker in left field
it had to end sometime but
oh boy is it a welcome sight nine runs
on nine hits all in the fourth
here's springer he has struck out and
fouled out
george sends one deep to left field and
he found that pitch
springer hits his third home run of the
year and gets two runs back for the
astros they are now down by the score of
nine to six
time for nick ahmed to join the hit
parade
this is hit out to left center field
nick ahmed gives it a ride it's gone
first of the year for nick make it 11-6
david peralta the hitter and they added
two more runs in the bottom of the fifth
on a nick ahmed home run and now peralta
sends one into the pool
the first of the year for the freight
train and it's 12-6
water escobar the one guy in the lineup
that has not had a base hit
escobar down the line and that one is
gone for a home run
eduardo escobar just able to keep it
fair down the line
and it's 14-7 the first of the year for
el dilapica